thank you
that is the sound of our top story
tonight wild new videos seeming to show
people opening fire during what police
say was a dangerous Street takeover four
people were hurt one of those victims
apparently fighting for their life
and thank you for joining us here at six
o'clock I'm Denise Valdez and I'm Brian
Loftis you can see that smoke and hear
the gunshots as well then you see the
vehicles just taking off as officers
arrive police report this happened near
Paradise and sunset very early Sunday
morning just a few blocks south of Harry
Reid International Airport that is where
we now find eight news now reporter
Joshua peguero joining us live with more
information
hello Brian and Denise this is where
Metro says on Sunday morning A Street
takeover took place I'm gonna step out
of the way so my photographer can zoom
in and show you the Tire Max still left
in an area with a lot of Corporate
Office Buildings now those tire marks a
result of dozens of cars some of them
doing donuts right before gunshots start
to go off take a look at the video
shared by Metro capturing that chaos
[Music]
thank you
now Metro says this all started when a
man tried getting inside of a car one of
the victims confronted that person and
then a fight took place which then led
to several people firing their guns now
you're taking a look at a surveillance
camera from one of the Office Buildings
we stopped by at least three different
buildings no one inside wanted to go on
camera but we were told from one of
these companies that they have security
24 7 monitoring the area and one of the
security guards witnessed that incident
reporting live at Bermuda and pilot
Joshua peguero eight news now